evil geniuses are spring 2022 lcs
champions they'll now be heading off to
msi to represent north america and
honestly
not a lot of people saw this coming it
was an insane lower bracket run in the
playoffs for them they swept aside some
of the region's most veteran talent and
provided us with potentially the single
greatest play in the lcs's nine-year
history 2v5 is possible i mean you're
not going to stop the baron but you
might get a team fight he's going to
shoot
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
all right then if this video gets you
all pumped up to watch eg at msi then
just have a little look down below make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
because we'll have plenty of videos on
that coming in the future also leave us
a like if you fancy it appreciate it
look if you've paid any attention to the
lcs since 2013 you'll have seen the same
names taking the title year after year
clg tsm c9 tl these were the teams that
swapped the trophy between them and it
was only last year that hundred thieves
became the fifth orb to ever be crowned
champions well now you can make that six
eg are champions but honestly only their
most die-hard fans would have said this
was coming just a few short weeks ago
they finished a respectable fourth place
in the regular season with a nine and
nine record this earned them a spot in
the upper bracket but they were quickly
bounced out of that by a 3-2 loss to
team liquid in the lower bracket they
took down flyquest in fairly comfortable
fashion but the most interesting part of
that series for me turned out to be the
single game they dropped in that 3-1
victory and that's because from that
moment on that would be the last game
the eg would drop for the rest of
playoffs they swept cloud9 3-0 to earn
themselves another showdown with team
liquid in the lower bracket final and
this fascinated a lot of fans on the one
hand you had team liquid the closest
thing that na has to a super team for
2022 they brought in european legends
blippo and han summer to join veterans
santorin and core jj they rounded out
the roster with a little known dane in
the mid lane known as bjergsen to put it
simply this team was built to [ __ ]
people up and that's exactly what they
did for most of the regular season by
finishing first and despite getting
reverse swept by 100 thieves in the
playoffs upper bracket they were still
the favorites going up against eg this
second time round eg on the other hand
are far from a super team sure they have
impact who won worlds when some other
players probably couldn't tie their own
shoelaces yet vulcan and inspired are no
strangers to winning either but it was
the other two members of the team whose
names will be mentioned whenever people
talk about these playoffs in the future
danny and jojo pioneer it was danny in
particular that pulled off a play that
will go down in lcs history with danny
dead in game one eg took a 4v5 fight to
stop team liquid at baron team liquid's
numbers pulled them through and they
limp back to finish the objective but
now danny was alive again he had his
jinx rockets and he smelled blood 2v5 is
possible i mean you're not going to stop
the baron but you might get a team fight
he's going to shoot you're kidding me
fights early
here comes kill number two
[Applause]
kobe can you believe it the 18 year old
from honolulu baby danny saves the game
for eg i mean
it doesn't get better than that a barren
steel pen to kill is what gets league
players up in the morning most 80
carries i know would trade their pinky
for that in their silver three game
never mind a domestic final there were
some small victories from team liquid in
the next two games but it felt like they
were trying to fight back the tide and
eg eventually shut them out in another
clean sweep the clutch gene belongs to
the young guns of eg they will crush
team liquid and eg will head to their
first ever lcs final honestly at this
point i'm not sure if it was the insane
jinx play from danny or the fact that it
was tl that got knocked out of playoffs
but i think a lot of us forgot that this
wasn't even the grand final yet the next
day in the grand final eg faced off
against hundred thieves who had been
building up their own hype too they were
the defending champions they were the
ones that knocked tiel down to the lower
bracket closer and abidargae seemed to
be reaching their final form they look
great but over the course of the series
eg out team 400 thieves hard across the
board a jinx ban in game 2 and a great
early game from closer wasn't enough to
slow eg down who were banging on the
nexus by the 24th minute so the series
was at 2-0 now for a lot of neutrals
like myself a broken tsm fan many of us
were hoping for a five-game final the
chance to hear silver scrapes and
remember hundred thieves had pulled off
the reverse sweep against team liquid
just a week before but this was eg's
playoffs this was eg's day this was eg's
final game and they weren't gonna let
anyone take that away inspired and
vulcan very low on hp it's gonna be
stolen by inspired how do eg keep
winning all of these neutral objective
fights
he's ready to go but he cannot do it
they're not done yet someday still
looking danny's stepping up
avada looks foolish in front of jojo and
he gee gets boom
they've got the teleport coming in they
might still look for something here
someday's going to see inspired who
immediately goes to the del gambadaga
trying to find something but he only
finds his grave eg in a 5v4 someday
tries to go in but now he's stuck in a
golden statue he flashes out to stay
alive but he can't do the same fbi
trying to skirt around this fight trying
to find anything but he only finds a
dredge line vulcan has him solved vulcan
goes for the dredge line but he won't
get it jojo in stasis and the fight is
already over 100 thieves are getting ran
into the ground
and eg
with a perfect
ace it is the fastest finals
ever and it never felt this good to be
bad evil geniuses
are your new
lcs champion
as captain flowers said just there this
was the fastest lcs finals in the
league's nine-year history it took eg
just an hour and 18 minutes to finish
off 100 thieves across the three games
that's an average of just 26 minutes per
game it's just ridiculous but the real
headline here is the fact that eg did
all of this with homegrown north
american talent in the form of danny and
jodopian and these guys didn't just show
up to help a little bit either as you've
probably gathered from this video they
practically carried eg over the finish
line at times it's difficult to convey
just how quickly these guys have risen
to the top this time last year danny was
honing his skills on eg's academy team
last summer he won the rookie of the
year award and now he's the lcs title
holder at the age of 18. and that's
don't even get me started on jojo
he's 17 years old this is the young
canadian's first split out of the
academy roster and two years ago he was
a fortnight pro i'm not kidding there's
a video of him destroying tifu back in
the day with over 800 000 views he was a
prolific stream sniper who was known to
1v1 the big names and just batter them
these are the guys that are the current
lcs champions their rise has been
meteoric and it's brought up the same
old argument of domestic versus imported
talent guys like danny and jojo are
living proof that na can produce quality
players that the default of importing
from china or europe might not be the
only way to succeed of course they're
still both the exception to the rule
right now and all owners have years of
successful import stories to point to
when deciding their rosters but bloody
hell at least these lads have given the
region some hope of course as we all
know there's a very fine line between
hopium and copian but i'm really excited
to see these guys represent na at msi
soon all that stuff i just said about
how young and inexperienced some of
these players are or how they're
actually from north america imagine the
absolute scenes if they take down the
likes of a g2 a t1 or an rng at an
international tournament like msi listen
you might do the usual and tell north
american fans to just calm down but how
can they when they hear something like
this jojo talk to me about turning
towards international because that's
what you guys have earned not just that
trophy not just the north american crown
and possibly the start of a new dynasty
you earned the right to represent north
america on the international stage at
msi i know that you've got a lot of
confidence in the way you play that's
another echelon
where's your mind at what are you
thinking
i mean i saw the msi bracket we're
against eu so i mean i think we're going
to show you you but we'll have to see
i don't know what to do for them
all right well i don't know sorry colton
there's nothing there i mean i think
there might be some funny
clips
earlier on there wasn't i don't know
we'll figure it out we didn't
so yep colson he didn't